we got to say the magic words otherwise
it's not going to work light as a
feather stiff as a board light as a
feather stiff as a board light is a
feather chances are if you've been to a
sleepover you've heard ghost stories
tried to contact the dead read fortunes
and attempted to make your friends
levitate Bloody Mary Ouija light as a
feather stiff as a board concentrate
they're scary and entertaining and
participating in them can be a right of
passage for children and maybe even
adults
but do you know the histories behind
them do they actually work and
furthermore why do we love to scare each
other so much so join us for one hell of
a slumber
party hello hey do you want to come to a
sleepover I'm Dr Emily zarka and this is
monstrum the concept of a slumber party
has been around since the 19th century
when private bedrooms became the norm
and group sleeping became more fun than
function the sleepover was solidified as
a social institution when it was
recognized in newspapers and Society
journals in the early 20th century the
sleepover turned a bit more spooky
according to the Mary Dawson game book
the slumber party was the latest and
most popular Affair for a young girl the
book describes the ideal sleepover as
hosted in a bedroom with a fireplace
adding to the atmosphere to inspire
spooky stories and fortune telling the
sleepover became a right of passage at
least for Americans by the end of the
1920s particular particularly for girls
and young women and they still have that
reputation today at early sleepovers
communal fir lights set the scene for
what would become a fundamental
ingredient spooky games a good ghost
story could win a girl a prize palms
would be read and Fortune's told
Driftwood powder would be thrown on the
Flames to produce all the colors of the
rainbow a bit of science disguised as
magic Driftwood especially if it's from
the ocean will burn in different colors
mostly shades of blue and light purple
due to the presence of a absorbed metal
salts things like copper oxide and
copper sulfate when you burn the wood
you're adding energy to the atoms in the
salts they can lose that energy Again by
releasing light different elements give
off different colors just like fireworks
where the specific mix of ingredients
many of the metals create a whole
rainbow of bursts but don't try this
Driftwood magic at home it is literally
toxic levitation games or tricks have
been a Pastime for children for
literally hundreds of years no really
records from the 17th century note this
curiosity in discussion of children's
folklore and the first written mention
of levitation games appears in the Diary
of Samuel peps it details a spell
performed by four French girls as they
lifted a little boy in a Pudo
Resurrection in the mid-14th century a
horrific plague many today know as the
Black Death swept through the region
what may have begun is a way for kids to
confront the death that surrounded them
during times of plague and a mass death
endured as a Lial game
you probably know what this looks like
participants lay only a couple of
fingers on the resurrect and chant in
1843 sir David Brewster's letters on
natural magic addressed to Sir Walter
Scott described the ritual with a phrase
that would give rise to a part of the
well-known chant to his own surprise in
that of his bearers he rises with the
greatest facility as if he were no
heavier than a feather I don't I don't
know I yet for the leverage
yeah too sweet okay I'm I'm going to try
not to laugh oh no
no no in reality of course the person is
not suddenly as light as a feather but
instead they weigh exactly the same as
what gravity says they do when the trick
works it's simply because the weight of
the body is distributed among four
people and eight hands you're not
lifting a 60 kilo person with your
fingers you're just lifting 15 kilos
which is very within reason and often
those attempting the light as a feather
ritual they try to lift the body without
saying the magic words then they fail
but when the ritual words are repeated
the lift Works light as aaff as a light
as aaff as aard light as a feather S as
a light as AA as a light AA the words
hold no magic Beyond unconsciously
signaling everyone to lift at precisely
the same time a spookier version of
counting down 3 2 1 this is an illusion
of control where our brains assume a
cause and effect link for two events
that simply just happened close in time
and centuries later kids are still
trying to levitate their friends with
chance why do kids want to scare each
other at parties the communal aspect of
these games and rituals is an important
facet not only are participants bonding
when they are pushed outside of their
emotional Comfort zones they offer
opportunities to demonstrate maturity by
showing courage in the face of fear
they're a right of passage an event that
marks transition or
growth Right comes from the Latin Rus
meaning religious observance ceremony or
behavior and the phrase right of passage
yeah much more recent the turn of the
20th century the same time the sleepover
really took off coincidence I don't
think so the term is generally credited
to French ethnographer and folklorist
Arnold van GF who in 1909 argued that
these ceremonial events involved a
sequence of three distinct Parts
separation transition and incorporation
sleepover games fall albeit Loosely
under the Hallmarks of this definition
separating from The Familiar both one's
home and comfort level a transition the
participation in the spooky test or
celebrated ritual and finally
reincorporation back into one's own home
at the end of the sleepover a Lial space
is an in between one familiar but not
entirely comfortable there's a level of
discomfort sleeping in a space that's
not your own and sleepovers occur first
and frequently during a limal age
puberty which is terrifying enough
without adding all the scary stories and
while under adult supervision they are
peer-run environments that promote
activities not allowed in everyday life
life granting children an opportunity to
explore their own identities eating
marshmallows until you get sick staying
up way past bedtime and summoning ghosts
yeah not usually a kids's daily routine
sleepovers aren't all about rebellion
but curiosity exploration and
Independence on the cusp of adulthood
many children and teens want to test the
boundaries of what is known literally
and metaphysically one ritualistic
practice that really test boundaries is
communicating with the dead or trying to
at least in my experience and fun fact
while the slumber party was gaining
popularity in the 19th century so was
another social Trend spiritualism in
1848 young teen sisters Kate and Maggie
Fox developed a cult following for their
reported ability to communicate with the
dead via a coded rapping technique they
took their act on tour demonstrating
their abilities to large pain audiences
ushering the spiritualist movement into
popular culture participants in the
spiritualist movement believed the soul
lived on past death and tried to seek
guidance from the spirit world at small
group occasions often led by an employed
medium while attempting to communicate
with the deceased is nothing new in
human history spiritualism took these
practices out of religious or
traditional ceremonies and into the
popular imagination drawing rooms public
Halls theaters camps and other Leisure
spaces join Believers and Skeptics
together to witness communication into
the Afterlife objects might levitate
Spirits could leave their impression on
photographic plates whisper in the
medium's ear or tap on a table there
were certainly True Believers in the
spiritualist movement but even for the
more skeptical The Experience itself was
important that Collective Fear
Experience that offered the possibility
of an inexplicable mysterious event was
too tantalizing to miss people who
didn't have access to mediums would
engage in other small rituals attempting
to communicate with the dead or see into
the Future q Bloody Mary if you've seen
monstrum Bloody Mary episode you already
know that in the early 20th century mirr
divination rituals were popular ramping
up during the Halloween season young
adults particularly women turn to the
mirror to see into the future often with
the intention of identifying their
future spouse the Bloody Mary variation
is one of the simplest as it only
requires three things a dark room a
mirror and a chant I'm not I'm trying
not to Blink and I'm trying to make eye
contact with myself so I feel like I'm
seeing something here oh out of the Corn
oh God the TV no you unplugged it m
that's what happened no it didn't that
was an unplugged TV tools some
spiritualists use to connect to the dead
also made their way into sleepover
tradition like the Ouija board in
February 1891 Baltimore inventor Elijah
J Bond patented a toy or game called
Ouija or Egyptian luck board supposedly
he named the game on the advice of his
sister-in-law a medium who asked the
board what it wanted to be called it's
spelled Ouija talking boards simple
boards with printed letters predate the
Ouija and served essentially the same
purpose to communicate with Spirits
however bonds intent wasn't a means of
spirit communication the patent says
that the player's touch of the hand is
what moves the planet capitalism this
was not the only parlor game marketed to
communicate with the dead but it would
become the most popular Ouija really
took off in the 20th century when it
began appearing in pop culture texts in
1920 a book our unseen guest followed
the story of a married couple who began
to communicate with a World War I
Soldier after they discovered a Ouija
board on Halloween anonymously published
and marketed as non-fiction it contains
two letter dictated by the spirit
himself in 1990 the authors were
revealed to be two newspaper reporters
and closet spiritualists but it was a
1973 horror movie that would Skyrocket
the Ouija board's notoriety and
popularity The Exorcist hey where did
this come
from the movie adapts William Peter
Batty's novel about a young girl
possessed by a demon after playing with
a Ouija board she discovers in the
basement other pop culture references to
Ouigi frequently show the game played
collectively sometimes the game
contributes more to Comedy like in Sugar
and Spice or friends but more often it's
AOK to help scare the audience like in
Ouija 13 Ghosts The Conjuring 2 or
Veronica while Legends like Bloody Mary
are evoked in ritual these are done
primarily to incite fear rather than
actually summon a spirit a Ouija board
blurs the line between occult practices
and playful evocation of Terror some
Scholars argue that publicly vocal
fundamentalists Christians in the 1970s
along with the satanic Panic of the
1980s contributed to a shift in perspec
Ive of these so-called occult sleepover
games both movements attributed any
dabbling in the occult as inviting in
the devil associating such practices
with the Demonic wait is it actually
this no oh my God wait what what what
what you it has to be you're lying it's
100% you're in a smile it'sin one of you
is messing with I'm not doing it whether
you believe or not it's hard to deny the
omnipresent reach of the Ouija game
today with the board's familiar
lettering appearing on rugs shirts mints
fake nails and throw blankets everywhere
nervous to dabble in the spirit world
for answers about the future you could
always try concentrate this trans game
is meant to predict how you will die and
involves a really creepy poem SL ritual
designed to give someone the chills the
origins of this one are very vague and
no Dwight did not invent it my best
guess is it developed during the mid
20th century as a messed up form of
guided meditation meant to scare people
fun fact I remember playing this as a
kid not at a sleepover but during recess
at my Catholic School supposedly the
color you see after being pushed
indicates how you will die in the future
more than trying to experience a
supernatural event these rituals are
about creating connection with the other
participants and testing boundaries fear
can challenge us and traumatize us but
it can also Bond us strange games in
Lial spaces allow us to confront the
unknown in safe environments preparing
us for the many unexpected mysteries of
life
[Music]
before you go I wanted to remind you
that a new season of our sister show
fate and fabled is underway join me and
Dr mctt for an allnew series of the
wildest most adventurous and sometimes
weirdest stories from our Strange
world's folklore and mythologies right
here on storied but it was a 1973 horror
movie that would Skyrocket the Ouigi
board board Luigi board Luigi board so
evocation is right yeah
a